me
ビーン
今から12年前
当時勤めていた感謝デー
お客様をお見送りした時に
その車の排気ガスから
天ぷら油のにおいがしました
私はびっくりして
天ぷら油の匂いがしますねと尋ねました
すると
この車は天ぷら2で走っているからねっとおっしゃいます
嘘でしょうと言うとじゃあ鑑賞見においでと言われました
私は好奇心からその会社に行きました
そしてその会社で実際に燃料を見せてもらいます
それでも
信じられなかった私は
その燃料を少し分けていただいてある大学に持ち込みます
そこで初めて
俳優からエネルギーができること
そしてその燃料の素晴らしさを知ります
それが今私が仕事でやっているバイオディーゼル燃料との出会いです
こちらをご覧ください
これは
繁殖湯です
私はこの繁殖湯からバイオディーゼル燃料という
軽油の代替燃料を作っています
バイオディーゼル燃料
これは
トラックやバス重機発電機そして船など
ディーゼルエンジン搭載のものであれば何にでも使えます
そしてこの燃料には敬意にはない
素敵な特徴が3つあります
まず1つ目
co2が0カウントということ
そして2つ目
ケールに比べて
硫黄酸化物がほとんど含まれないということ
そして3つ目は黒煙がほとんど
1/3以下ほとんど出ないということです
そして何より私たちでエネルギーを作ることができます
こんなにステキなバイオディーゼル燃料の原料である
藩主 p ですが
日本中で年間どのくらいの量が廃止されると思いますか
配色裏ワ日本中で約年間45万トン排出されています
そのほとんどが
資料や工業用として再利用されていますが
埋め立てやゴミとして燃やされ再利用されていない廃食油は年間約18万トンもあり
ます
もし
この midi を分の廃食油18万トンをすべて
バイオディーゼル燃料にすることができたら
大型トラックだと約30万台分を満タンにすることができます
地域から出るこの繁殖湯
この地域の資源を地域の人の手でエネルギーに変えて地域のエネルギーとして使用する
そんな未来のエネルギーの形を作りたいです
繁殖湯は何処にでもあります
太陽があって植物が育ってそこに人の営みがあれば世界中どこにでも存在します
そして
皆さんその処理に困っています
これは事業としてきっとうまくいく
私はそう信じ
地元の経営者の方々に事業の一つとして取り組みませんかと提案をしました
提案をしてまずびっくりしたことそれはそのほとんどの方がバイオディーゼル燃料の
ことを知っていたんです
環境に良いことも co2ゼロカウントということも
ディーゼルエンジン搭載であれば何にでも使用できることを皆さんご存知でした
でも次にびっくりしたこと
私よりも詳しくこの燃料の良さを知っているのに皆さん
事業としてやらないって言うんです
びっくりでしょ
相手の方に言わせると事業としてやりませんかとものすごい勢いで話を持ってきた私に
びっくりしたとおっしゃいます
さて
皆さんが縁をそろえて事業としてやらないという理由
それは儲からないから
儲からないから商売として成り立たないだからやらないっておっしゃるんです
でも私にはどうしてもそう思えませんでした
唱題したこともないしするつもりもなかった私ですけれども
でも
これは絶対にやれるという根拠のない自信だけ
持ってしまったんです
でも誰もやらないって言うんです
皆さんならどうしますか
私は誰もやらないと言うから
自分で始めました
それが今から約5年前です
夢いっぱいに
始めた授業でしたが起業してすぐ
親兄弟親戚知人友人そして経営者の皆さんが絶対にやめた方がいいっていう理由を嫌と
いうほど知ることになります
当たり前ですが繁殖にはもうすでにその処分の流れができていました
夜
一人で会社に入ると
変な電話がかかってきます
月の無い夜の暗さを知っとるかとか
するとかねぇ
卵パとか
私はうるさいからだっちゃんかちゃんテーマを切ってました
すると
もんのすごい聞こえデー
怒鳴られました
いたずらデマじゃなくって
今年の電話だったんです
お客様先に廃油を回収に行くと泥棒されてたり
朝会社に出勤してみるとドラム缶ごと
大事な原理を泥棒されてたり
いろんなことが毎日毎日起きる中でやっぱり
授業としてやるのは難しいのかなって考え始めました
そして
あまりにもまあ日前に持論のことが起きるので
本気で
会社を清算することを考えたしました
その時です
ある人が私にこう言いました
せっかく良いことやってるのに一時凹むのは不釣り合いだよ
ちゃんと応援しているよ
そしてさらにその人が言いました
諦めの悪い奴が3周的には勝つ
だから諦めの悪い人になろう
諦めが悪いという言葉はどちらかというとマイナスイメージを持っていました
でもその言葉が私に
勇気とやる気をくれました
そして
私なんでこの授業をやりたいのかなぁって改めて考えました
バイオディーゼル燃料は地産地消エネルギーです
その地産地消エネルギーの歯が熊本から九州に広がって日本に広がってそれが世界に
広がった時の地球の姿を想像したときにキラキラとした地球しか想像できなかった私は
そうそういう地球を次の世代に引き継ぎたい
そしてそれが仕事として関われるならこんなに素敵なことはない
よし諦めの悪い人になろう
応援してくれる仲間もいっぱいいる
第あって後悔をしないようにだけ使用
そう決めたらあとはできることをコツコツとやり続けるだけです
徹底的に
品質を追求しました
その結果最新の
クリーンセプクリーンディーゼル車にもお使いいただける
ハイクオリティな燃料が完成します
こちらをご覧ください
これ
水じゃないんですよ
これは私たちが作ったハイクオリティな燃料熊井音です
減圧蒸留するとこんなにも綺麗になります
この燃料の特徴が
安定的に最新式のバイオディーゼル
者にもお使いいただけます
おっ
では世界の再生可能エネルギー消費を見てみましょう
2001年アメリカは群を抜いていますが
その他の国々はほとんど変わりありません
ですがそれから約10年後
アメリカーもちろんのこと他の国々も消費量が伸びています
でも日本は
ほとんど変わりありません
ではこの日本地図で自然エネルギーの供給率を見てみましょう
やはり
全国的に見て日本は非常に低いです
でももし
私が住んでる熊本が
2030年までにこの自然エネルギー供給率50%という目標立てたとしましょう
この数字は一企業がとなに頑張っても実現できるものではありません
でも一人一人の意識と行動を少し変えるだけで実は
実現可能なんですね
私は
まず自分の住んでいるこの九州を
自然エネルギー供給リズ日本一にしたいです
今までの私がそうだったように
どんなに無謀だと思えることでも
そこに
支えてくれる仲間ゲーテ
その仲間とともに
共感できる未来を描くことができれば
実現できないことなんて何ひとつない
私はそれを日々実感しています
そして今また一つ大きなチャレンジを
しています
こちらをご覧くださいこの写真
皆さん何に見えますか
来れば
熊本の三大火祭りの一つ
古墳さあで使用された私たちのバイオディーゼル燃料です
これ
成果に見えませんか
2020年
日本でオリンピックが開催されますよね
そのオリンピックに参加したいと思いませんか
環境に配慮し
持続可能なオリンピックを目指している2020年の東京オリンピックパラリンピック
の場に私たちの台所から出た
繁殖湯が原料となってイカされる
その燃料は地球にやさしく
メイドインジャパンの燃料です
もしこの夢が実現したときには皆さんお家で揚げ物をいっぱいしてくださいね
熊本の小さな会社の大きな夢ですがもしこれが実現したらそれは
諦めず失敗を恐れずチャレンジし続けたからです
そして
私とともに未来の自然環境を夢見て共感し支えてくれる仲間がいるからです
これからも
できることをコツコツとやり続けて自分の
思い描く未来の自然環境に少しでも近づくことができるよう
努力していきます
ありがとうございました